der achter knoten gesteckt findet beim
anteil beim bau von verankerungen und
der bergrettung verwendung
das heil ende wird eineinhalbfach
eingedreht und von hinten durch die
entstehende schlaufe gesteckt
das heil wird in den gewünschten
jetzt wird das seil parallel zum bereits
bestehenden achter zurückgeführt
kreuzungen sollten gleich vermieden
werden damit sich der knoten nach dem
eher belastet wurde leicht öffnen lässt
die dadurch entstehende schlaufe soll so
klein als möglich sein
achtet hier besonders
auf dass das seil ende nicht mehr als
den zehnfachen sein durchmesser
übersteht